- But Sam and Aaron you work together
and you're also married,
I work with my husband
closely too he's my manager,
how does that work, like when
you're directing him though
that's a different kind of thing.
(laughs)
Yeah I wanna hear what that's about,
that moment of silence.
(laughs)
- I think because we met that way,
we already had that short
hand in that language
and so we step back on the set
and it just continued in
that way really, yeah.
- Yeah it was very natural yeah.
- What do you wanna say about that.
- I'm actually gonna get--
- I enjoyed it.
- To a really awesome
question I can't wait to ask.
Because I always, my husband and I
have this conversation all the time,
it's like actors there's a love scene.
And you're like watching
your man have a love scene
like I am like,
I'm like what?
Like how is that?
- Okay we're gonna go there.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Is that hard?
- Well I'll tell you.
- Is it hard, like I know
it would be really hard.
- Well firstly we wrote it and you know,
you write it in a way
which is fairly, you know,
you're focusing on the scene
and how it's gonna play out
and then you're on set and
Odessa is an amazing actress,
and the two of them and
I'm composing the scene
and I'm looking at it
and we're working on it
and we're shooting it
over four or five hours,
and it's really a beautiful
scene and incredibly intimate.
- And you probably just get in the zone.
- You get in the zone and
then there was just one moment
where I turned to my
assistant director and I said,
really you had to schedule
this on Valentines day!
(audience laughs)
- Oh my gosh!
- I said I know I'm
professional and I'm a director,
but I'm a human being and ah (laughs).
- Oh my gosh, that
Valentine's like salt, wound.
- This little moment where,
dam let's hope he's a really good actor.
(audience laughs)
- Well no but that's gotta be,
that's gotta be awkward
for you though Aaron,
'cause you are a good actor,
so you wanna like be a good actor,
but at the same time you're like,
I ain't enjoying this!
- She said this too
convincing I don't know,
so drawn between the two.
You did get your own back though,
I mean the next morning
she had me and Giovanni
butt naked in the shower and
decided to go for a wide shot.
- Oh I love it, you got him
back I love it, I love it.